Kevin Hart teases the new Jumanji great
zip good girl the 37 year old actor is
currently filming the much anticipated
movie due out July 2017 and et caught up
with him in New York where he led us in
on what fans can expect from the flick I
don't want people to think that we're
redoing Jumanji it's a continuation okay
if you mind you was to move on this is
what it would be we would never you know
touch something as good as that and try
to make it our own what we're doing is I
think if that was still there and is it
new doing this is what it will be so I
think the audience is in for a treat you
know not only have a great cast got a
great time right there and I think so
he's done a great job and putting the
film together and we're in Hawaii we're
in a jungle so you're getting the real
effect and I'm much better than the
Wayne Johnson in this movie all kidding
aside kevin has had a pretty epic week
filming Jumanji getting a star on the
Hollywood Walk of Fame and having his
new film what now hit theaters but he
doesn't let the success go to his head I
try not to think about those things I'm
excited about where I am in life more
importantly I understand what it takes
to get here
work dedication and I'm at a point where
I don't plan on slowing down anytime
soon